when a movie doesn't have a proper
ending it kind of leaves you hanging how
do you say that like it did have you
seen infinity war yet yeah okay in my
language my niece is asking me at the
kalaiy what's bitten in English like :
we think I'll movie meaning like how do
you say that in English because she's
trying to explain it to an American boy
she's going on a date with she what
she's my date well it's a guy who's
asking her on a date than American boys
she doesn't know how to explain that the
movie was like cliffhanger cliffhanger
but is that what it's called a fair but
let me say something every single person
that I've talked to about that movie
said it's the best out of all the movies
is it true you're talking about infinity
war no I'm talking about [ __ ]
Apocalypse Now oh okay you know if you
talk about the quiet place yeah I'm
talking about the [ __ ] infinity where
you [ __ ] [ __ ] it's not only the best
one if you if you put the time to watch
all the other ones the payoff is greater
if you watch I've seen Oliver asked me I
asked me a question okay
what is the actor's name black panther
that plays no that that's not that's not
a storyline thing okay what is that I
don't know anyone with name I I don't
even know I barely knew Will Smith's
name I called the black guy okay Fresh
Prince who is the villain and uh the
First Avenger
Captain America First Avenger the
villain of the Captain America yet the
actor was Hugo Weaving but what's the
character's name Decepticon exactly I
don't know I don't know I think you'd
like it
oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah but if
you've seen all of them yeah you'll just
know it's a lot of lot of payoff if
you'd haven't seen any of them you've
been a bad boy them all I think I can
watch it and go okay I kind of get the
gist of it but I heard it was great it
was a Russo brothers did it
you've worked with him they did animal
practice oh yeah that's right so I was
on a sitcom called the animal practice
with Justin Kirk and Anthony Russo and
his brother Joe yeah you know were the
producers of it I auditioned for Anthony
he called NBC and just said just hire
him I did animal practice got cancelled
and now they're the they're like they
did they did um just listen
Captain America winter winter winter
soldier
winter winter I call it the double
winter is civil civics case civil war
whatever so I saw a civics case and went
to inter yeah great movies the Russo
brothers did that and then I did this
one Infinity's oh you might get a cameo
then in a future mom no they do it they
give it to all people they've worked
with they've got me they're going
they're going backwards in a timeline
well they used Annie I know that Yeah
right
Adi I did his pilot you know Danny and
Sung Kang yeah oh it's a fast and
furious what's the show I saw up I did I
did a I did a um their pilot a guest her
and I had two lines and then my arm
breaks and then blood spews on Danny's
face and that was my scene oh it was so
funny because I love Sung Kang hmm you
know if you ever see the Korean dramas I
did on MADtv Sung Kang is the star of
that main star he's a good-looking
Korean dude but he's in the Fast &
Furious the Tokyo Tokyo han yeah hon
right and he is one of the night he used
to own a restaurant in Brentwood I used
to go to all the time a Japanese
restaurant or something with his wife
but he asked me to do it and at first
first you know whispers because I don't
know yeah yeah at first I didn't want to
do it because you know small thing I
can't say no to people what's the last
time you said no to a project never well
no he can't say no if they personally
call him yeah if I think they personally
call me like I have an audition I'm not
gonna say what it is but tonight after
we're done with this I have to put
myself on tape with George and I at
first I wasn't gonna do it but then the
star of it and the writer of that
contact contacted me personally and goes
can you do it and I'm like I'll do it
and I don't want to do it not because I
it's because of the fact that I just I'm
lazy you're gonna do it yeah I'm gonna
do it
I'm gonna [ __ ] it anyway I'm gonna
[ __ ] do
[Music]